nouveau numéro de reporter sur france 24
direction la côte d'ivoire et plus
précisément le nord du pays où plane la
menace du jihadisme nous parlons de
cette région située à la frontière avec
le burkina faso au nord-est du pays et
que les groupes armés
burkinabé utilise comme une zone de
repli en l'espace de deux ans cinq
attentats non revendiqués ont été
perpétrés le plus important en juin 2020
contre un poste militaire a fait 14
morts et depuis le quotidien des
habitants est devenue très compliquée en
plateau avec nous samuel bernard bonjour
samuel vous êtes le correspondant de
france 24 en côte d'ivoire on va
découvrir dans un instant votre
reportage situé tourner dans cette zone
extrêmement compliqué et ça n'a pas été
facile de d'y accéder alors tout à fait
ans après en fait l'attentât de juin
2020 il était quasiment impossible en
fait de se rendre sur place c'est
seulement en janvier 2022 donc un an et
demi après ces attentats que l'armée
ivoirienne a mis en place une forme de
corridors sécurisés à landon de la ville
de kafo l'ovaire tougbo qui nous a
permis en fait de rencontrer les
populations et donc d'avoir le d'obtenir
leur leurs témoignages alors ça c'est en
janvier et ensuite en avril nous avons
pu suivre une brigade de l'armée
ivoirienne qui est donc chargé de
surveiller les points stratégiques au
long de la frontière avec le burkina
faso donc reportage vraiment dans une
zone où on a peu l'habitude de voir des
images côte d'ivoire la menace
djihadiste reportage que vous avez
tourné avec annan ferdjani et on vous
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
poste de commandement de kong à 600 km
d'abidjan les forces de sécurité se
prépare pour une sortie de nuit
ce soir des individus suspects ont été
signalés dans les environs tout près de
la frontière avec le burkina faso tout
personnel quittait après un des deux va
faire l'objet de fouilles qui va les
procédures opérationnelles que vous
connaissez nous allons effectuer des
patrouilles une patrie il a dans la zone
de calmes et et une patrouille ira dans
la zone de tous bords
ces militaires sont déployés à l'extrême
nord-est du territoire depuis la toute
première attaque jihadiste dans la
région survenu en juin 2020
à bord de véhicules blindés et en convoi
ces escadrons remonte vers la frontière
vous travaillez en garde dans une zone
d'action qui a beaucoup
car tu veux voilà ça c'est l'un de mes
ennemis est très sensible à
tout on a progressé c'est une élève
élément de tête a vu
les éléments jusqu'à ce qu'une autre
sinon par des progressions ils ont
débarqué ils sont atteints des faits la
fuite nous allons le voir de quoi il
s'agit nous
progressons vers val d'allier
par précaution les militaires avancent
doucement et en file indienne
ce soir pas d'engin explosif en vue mais
à 200 mètres de notre véhicule les
démineurs ont découvert un cratère au
sol
les jihadistes n'ont pas eu le temps d'y
poser une mine
lorsque
je donne de moins de pouvoir tenir au
fond d'un handicap les ponts comme celui
ci sont la cible privilégiée des groupes
armés
deux semaines plus tôt c'est tout près
d'ici que cette unité a essuyé des tirs
avant de repousser les assaillants des
escarmouches récurrentes sur lesquels
l'armée communique peu
la plus risquée de
capolo
dessin jaune jusqu'à un certain point en
particulier ses études et ont baissé
embuscade en plus qu'un particulier on
va en mode surtout c'est la première
fois en deux ans que l'armée autorise
des médias internationaux a assisté à
une de ces opérations antiterroristes au
nord officiellement les autorités ont
repris le contrôle de la zone mais les
éléments de langage répétés par le
lieutenant quand balles ont du mal à
convaincre
après les phases de jeu et léger
comme je l'aï dit tantôt nous sommes en
train de poursuivre on essaie de fait
notre
nez sans qu'on ait le faut
les mettre la population en confiance
[Musique]
les renforts continus à arriver dans la
zone déjà forte de quatre mille hommes
car malgré l'accalmie cette région
proche d'une bande sahélienne en proie
au terrorisme reste vulnérable
[Musique]
c'est le cas du village de cas folle au
théâtre de la première attaque jihadiste
dans la région
tout bascule dans la nuit du 10 au 11
juin en 2020 lorsque les habitants du
village sont réveillés par des tirs
paterne se souvient que cette nuit là
l'impact des balles du saint
loup tellement de nouveau à 2,3 déjà une
patte du feu ces corps sont ceux de 14
militaires burkinabè et ivoirien le
dernier vestige de cette asso
l'empreinte dans préfabriqués en bois
tout récemment retiré cette attaque est
considérée comme des représailles à une
opération militaire conjointe pour
déloger des djihadistes installé dans la
zone un coup dur pour la côte d'ivoire
quatre ans après l'attentât meurtrier de
grand bassam le saas est en jeu c'est
quand même bizarre la bd est bizarre on
savait qu'ils avaient quitté les parages
mais nous prépare
neuf mois plus tard deux soldats et un
gendarme ivoiriens sont tués ici ainsi
que trois terroristes ou puis dzeko
n'est pas que cela allait bien des
chiens en quoi
des fois c'est bien château
pattern nous conduit dans cet hôtel
autrefois prisé des touristes étrangers
aujourd'hui plus aucun visiteur en vue
avant la première attaque il dirigeait
une troupe de théâtre locale qui se
représentait dans cet établissement
c'est fermé selon nouvelle en nous et
cela j'ai ainsi ces fermes
dont 11 ouvriers s'ils avaient pu nous
rend très
risqué talent ici donc c'était bien où
il a passé ce qui rendrait décembre sa
part dans les guides sont pas liés pas
de partis tout est parti deux ans
termine pas par exemple travailler ici
la sarthe fin du mois de 15 ans et plus
à quelles fins de mois mais sera
beaucoup mon sens il avait une pie voilà
il lui arrive
à l'exception de deux employés qui
entretiennent les jardins et nourrissent
une poignée de chats poser c'est triste
à dire mais les gens les gardent ils ont
grimpé de gagner tv yang n'a réussi à
réunir la vie des doubles adecco paulo
n'a plus loin plus de l'issue n'a rien
malgré un large déploiement militaire le
long de la frontière ce qui reste de
l'économie locale comme l'agriculture où
la pêche souffre aujourd'hui de
l'insécurité ambiante car le mode
opératoire des groupes qui sévissent
dans la zone ne se limite pas à la tacc
armés ils entretiennent aussi le
sentiment de peur à travers
l'intimidation des populations comme
dans ce village situé à une poignée de
kilomètres de la frontière avec le
burkina faso
il y a un an des individus armés
pénètrent dans la localité réunissent la
population autour de la mosquée et
accuse des personnes d'être des
informateurs des forces de sécurité
nationale
[Musique]
alors que j ce cultivateur a accepté de
témoigner à condition de garder
l'anonymat alison wenham hood où il doit
plaider des trains
ou si il y en a 5 à 10 par la peña 10 à
la tenue à la radio c'est du banc
et celle ci
n'a pas voulu
nous légaliser
mais directement
depuis leur passage la vie a changé ici
les villageois évite les longs
déplacements aucune moto ne circule
après 18 heures on a un peu
loupé vos paramètres
de vol et
les habitants du village tente tant bien
que mal de tourner la page de la terreur
mais c'est la méfiance qui semble s'être
depuis installé dans la région la
méfiance envers une communauté en
particulier
celles d'éleveurs semi nomades qui
appartiennent à l'ethnie peule
au lendemain de la première attaque de
kafo folo les forces de sécurité
interpelle plusieurs responsables dont
un peuple du burkina faso aujourd'hui
les mesures de surveillance prises à
l'encontre des peuples de la région sont
à peine dissimulée par les autorités
locales
l'epl sont pointés du doigt depuis
plusieurs années dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme au mali et burkina faso
voisin il y en aurait entre 35000 et 48
dans la région ivoirienne du bon cani
selon des sources militaires
une communauté vivant essentiellement
dans des campements loger en pleine
brousse pour rester proche du bétail et
dont le quotidien est précarisé depuis
le début des incursions
me
ces deux éleveurs peuls sont nés et ont
grandi en côte d'ivoire cette région est
la seule qui connaissent
[Musique]
la ville
sont à madame alima immédiat le
coquen immobiliers obligatoires
mais une chose à savoir tubulaire en est
sûr qu il y ait
trop hâtive à la
mangue ou d'un bundle au nom qui le dit
ça pour
le maillot jaune il
en faut dix
nouveaux cas au dessus du montant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là ça n'a pas souri et le chef d'un
petit village du nom de nation figure
respectée dans le département il s'est
donné pour mission de soutenir la
communauté peule qui connaît très bien
donnez moi
là
bas souris a fait libérer une dizaine de
membres de la communauté peule ces
derniers mois il s'est plusieurs fois
rendu en personne à la gendarmerie de
conques chef lieu du département pour
témoigner en faveur de jeunes hommes
interpellés et signé une lettre
d'engagement pour obtenir leur
libération
selon lui il ne faut surtout pas céder à
la tentation du conflit
intercommunautaire
les militaires quand on voit cela
d'autres qui appelle pas foot et pas du
tout voir mais on va jusqu'à dans
l'encadrement hanté par ce sont
quasiment aucun ils sont venus on les a
installés
quand les installer on travaille
ensemble on vit ensemble sans problème
humanitaire cdh c'était un homme si tu
vois ton semblable en train de
maltraiter sa dette et fait mal c'est
normand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bassory espère que l'amélioration du
contexte sécuritaire permettra d'apaiser
les relations entre communautés de leur
côté les forces de sécurité assure ne
discriminent et aucune est mis dans leur
lutte contre le terrorisme la côte
d'ivoire a annoncé un recrutement de dix
mille soldats sur trois ans pour grossir
les rangs de son armée
est en plateau avec nous on retrouve
samuel bernard correspondant de france
24 en côte d'ivoire sem l on l'a vu les
populations peu le sont particulièrement
exposées est ce que il y à un risque de
conflit interethnique alors à mesure que
la situation sécuritaire depuis il faut
public depuis juin 2021 il n'ya plus
d'attentats seulement des escarmouches
entre donc l'armée ivoirienne et les
groupes locaux donc à mesure que la
situation s'améliore on va dire les
tensions intercommunautaires elle
diminue elle aussi alors depuis notre
départ nos informateurs nous donne nous
informe que les arrestations arbitraires
de deux personnes membres de la
communauté peule sont de plus en plus
rares il ya eu beaucoup également de
libération donc de prisonniers mais on
peut il faut quand même donc dire que la
méfiance elle persiste et ce pour deux
raisons les groupes qui opèrent donc
dans la région dans cette zone sont des
groupes qui sont par exemple comme la
cathine à macina sont dirigés par des
membres de la communauté peule et puis
il y a ces vieilles tensions ces vieux
conflit entre donc une communauté qui
pratique aussi le pastoralisme oui on le
voit dans vos images très belles images
d'ailleurs de ces ses troupeaux qui vont
en liberté d'une certaine manière tout à
fait et donc voilà qui sont en conflit
avec les agriculteurs locaux qui eux ont
un mode de vie plus sédentaire alors
pour éviter justement que la situation
de dérive vers un conflit
intercommunautaire à proprement parler
comme par exemple le burkina faso ou au
mali il faut avant tout et surtout
espérer que la situation sécuritaire
se maintiennent telle qu'elle est et
puis que les personnes à les habitants
de la localité
fassent le choix aussi du vivre ensemble
comme ce chef oui que l'on voit la fin
du c'est ce que j'allais dire on voit
qu'il ya des des gens pacifistes à
l'oeuvre pour faciliter la vie entre
communautés comment se positionne la la
côte d'ivoire sahel dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme dans cette région du sahel
alors la côte d'ivoire se positionne
comme un leader régional il faut
rappeler qu'en 2021 une académie
internationale de lutte contre le
terrorisme a été inaugurée avec la
france une académie qui a vocation à
former les armées de la sous région mais
bon le souci c'est que toutes les
relations entre les différents pays ne
sont pas forcément au beau fixe par
exemple depuis la crise des 49 soldats
ivoiriens arrêtés actuellement au mali
là si l'art les relations entre la côte
d'ivoire et le mali se détériore jour
après jour est d'ailleurs lors d'un
discours près des familles de ces 49
soldats le ministre de la défense
ivoirien s'est inquiété de voir que
cette crise puisse avoir un impact sur
la lutte contre le terrorisme merci
beaucoup samuel bernard correspondant de
france 24 en côte d'ivoire c'est la fin
de ce magazine merci de l'avoir suivi et
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
votre porte
[Musique]
on